smoke and in ensuing panic as The Siege
at mogadishu's hayat hotel entered its
second day Security forces were still
fighting the last gunman thought to be
somewhere on the hotel's top floor
from a safe distance locals say prayers
the loud shots of gunfire a reminder
that fighting isn't over
it started with explosions outside the
building a hotel popular with officials
then gunman stormed it
minutes before the blasts two of my
friends may God grant them Heaven told
me they were leaving but seconds later
they were both killed by the blast
people fled in confusion they were all
running to where they thought they'd be
safe the hotel began to fill with smoke
and flames and I saw one of the hotel
guards bleeding and another man wounded
many of the victims are believed to be
civilians children among those rescued
we are outside the hotel you can hear
gunfire this is the first major
terrorist attack in Mogadishu since
somalia's new leader took over in May
and it is seen as a sign that Al-Qaeda
linked shabab group is making an
unwelcomed comeback Sadia chowdry Sky
News